in other videos we have already started
talking about the price elasticity of
demand and what we're going to do in
this video is think about the factors
that might drive the price elasticity of
demand in a given market to be more or
less elastic so one could say that we're
gonna think about the determinants of
the price elasticity of demand now
before we even talk about those
determinants or those factors let's just
give ourselves a little bit of a review
of what an elastic or an inelastic
market might look like so let me draw my
price and quantity axes that we are
pretty familiar with at this point
so quantity on the horizontal axis price
on the vertical axis and remember price
elasticity of demand is percent change
in quantity for a given percent change
in price so a high elasticity would say
that you have a large percent change in
quantity for a given percent change in
price so high elasticity would look
something like this it would be a
flatter demand curve so this one it
might maybe look something like that so
all right that is high high elasticity
elasticity and low elasticity would be
that your percent change in quantity
does not change much depending on your
percent change in price so a low
elasticity the closer and closer we get
to a vertical curve the lower our
elasticity so a low elasticity would
look something like that a low
elasticity demand curve low elasticity
elasticity in other videos we even think
about a perfectly inelastic market in
which case you would have a vertical
demand curve but let's not think about
the factors that might lead us to be
closer to the high elasticity case or
closer to the low elasticity case so the
factors that economists will generally
point to are substitutes time frame
income share whether the market we're
talking about is about a luxury or
necessity and the narrowness of a market
so let's start with substitutes so let's
imagine first a world where there are
many substitutes for the good or service
that we're talking about many substance
and we could think of examples in our
heads for markets of goods or services
where there are many substitutes let's
say it's the market for Fuji apples well
the other substitutes are the other
types of apples out there Macintosh
apples and Red Delicious apples and all
of those and so for a given percent
change in price would you expect the
percent change in quantity demanded of
Fuji apples to change dramatically well
if there are many substitutes and only
the Fuji apples say get a lot more
expensive then people will go to the
substitutes they're more likely to go to
the Red Delicious or the McIntosh apples
so when you have many substitutes that
tends to lead to more elasticity more
elasticity people quantity I guess you
could say it would be very sensitive to
price and you could go the other way
around if you have a few substitutes few
substitutes
well then even if the price changes a
little bit or even if it changes a lot
people say well I don't know what I
could substitute that with so they might
still buy a reasonably similar quantity
so this would be less less elastic less
elastic
now what about time frame how does that
affect elasticity well imagine that you
are selling umbrellas and it is raining
right now so if we're thinking about a
short time frame while it is raining
then you could probably raise the prices
on umbrellas a good bit and assuming
that you have good foot traffic a lot of
people are probably going to be willing
to pay that price and so in a short time
frame in a short short time frame things
tend to be less elastic less elastic but
over a longer time frame it's a longer
time frame people might say hey you're
trying to really rip me off with those
umbrellas and take advantage of me
I can go someplace else and find
umbrellas I could go online or whatever
else and so there people tend to be more
sensitive to price on the longer time
frame
they can find their substitutes going
back to the previous determinant and so
things tend to be more elastic so once
again you could view elasticity as as
how sensitive quantity is to price so
next income share so let's first think
about something that makes up a very
small percentage of your income say
bubblegum and let's say bubblegum right
now is 25 cents and if it were to go to
50 Cent's that would likely reduce the
quantity demanded but it might not be so
significant because going from 25 cents
to 50 cents isn't gonna make a big
difference on for most people's
pocketbooks so in general the lower the
income share lower share of income the
less elastic the less elastic that
market is going to be but imagine
something that is a high share of income
so let's say we're talking about let me
just write it here so high share I share
of income so let's say we're talking
about an automobile and if people
already spending 20 percent or 30
percent of their income on that
automobile and that automobile were to
double the cost of that versus the
gumball drop or what a bubble gum well
then people just wouldn't even be able
to demand the same quantities that they
were able to before because their income
just can't support it they have other
things to spend that money on that extra
money because their incomes just can't
support it so they will be highly
sensitive to changes in price so high
sensitivity to changes in price more
elastic now what about luxuries versus
necessities well let's start with
necessities if this is something that
you absolutely need then even if the
price were to go up a good bit as long
as you can still afford it you might
still go for that thing so for example
let's say there's some medicine let's
say you're a diabetic and you need
insulin if you don't get insulin and
really bad things are going to happen if
they were to raise the price of insulin
by 20 30 40 percent assuming that you
could
still afford it you would still buy the
same quantity because you need that
insulin and so if something is a
necessity necessity you're going to be
less price sensitive the quantity is
going to be less sensitive to price and
so you're going to be less elastic but
if something's a luxury if we're talking
about you know gold tiaras and the price
of gold were to go up dramatically well
then a lot of people say oh I I might
not need that gold TR anymore it's
really not going to make a big
difference in my life
so in general luxuries luxury will be
associated with more elasticity now
there could be exceptions if something
is in kind of the ultra luxury category
and if maybe the price were to go up
maybe the people buying it it's a very
low share of their income and maybe it's
a brand that at least the people beside
buying it feel that there's no
substitute for it well then maybe it
might not be as sensitive but we're
talking about in broad generalities now
the last factor that is sometimes talked
about is the narrowness of the market
now what are we talking about there so
for example we could be talking about
the market market for apples or you
could talk about the market market for
food which of these markets they're kind
of both describing food but which one is
more narrow yes apples are a subset of
all food and so if we're going about the
market for apples the narrower situation
so if we're talking about the narrower
narrower market you tend to have more
substitutes so if the price of Apple's
go up people say well maybe I'm going to
go buy some pears or bananas or
something else instead of the apples and
so you're going to be more quantity will
be more sensitive to changes in price
and so you're gonna have more elasticity
but if you have a broader definition of
your market the market for food well now
the food looks a lot more like it's a
necessity there are very few substitutes
for food
if I stop eating food well I it's not
like I can eat you know change or just
live off of air or whatever else there's
very there's really no substitutes for
food it is an absolute necessity so the
broader the market definition so the
broader the market we tend to be dealing
with a less elastic less elast less
price elasticity of demand